[Música]
hoy vengo a contarles una historia con
la ayuda de tres objetos el primero ya
dispone un poco es el globo verde
para mí un globo significa dos cosas un
símbolo y un desafío
si lo pensamos relajadamente podríamos
decir que un globo tiene ciertas
similitudes con un pulmón se infla y se
desinfla con el aire que ponemos y
sacamos de él es por eso que uno de los
símbolos de la fibrosis quística
la fibrosis quística es una enfermedad
genética donde los fluidos corporales
son más espesos afecta todos los órganos
pero el mayor problema es en los
pulmones donde el moco es más viscoso y
no puede ser expulsado con normalidad
por lo que se queda ahí adentro y es un
foco de infecciones que se van haciendo
cada vez más frecuentes hasta que notar
el pulmón
por eso mismo que es verde
y el globo también del mismo color
luego verdes mocos esperanza una
combinación digamos original por lo
menos hasta el día de hoy la fibrosis
quística no tiene cura sólo se realizan
tratamientos paliativos para aliviar los
síntomas en la parte respiratoria hay
dos pilares fundamentales el tratamiento
mucolítico que es realizarse
nebulizaciones posiblemente han visto
nebulizaciones con agua en algún momento
estas son con compuestos más complejos
y la kinesioterapia que son técnicas de
movilización mecánica para sacar ese
moco una forma de hacer kinesioterapia
es con dispositivos de asistencia como
este llamado flutter sería algo así
divertidísimo no
imagínense así dos horas a la mañana y
dos horas las noches todos los días de
su vida en un año nos da la módica suma
de 1.460 horas
dicen que para ser experto en alguna
actividad
necesitamos mil horas de práctica por
ende yo soy experta en soplar esta cosa
porque al igual que una cada cinco mil
700 personas en la argentina
soy fiero quística y el frutero es parte
de mi día a día pero no quiero que se me
confundan no es el segundo objeto
un día a los 13 años estaba en la
escuela en clase de música y el profesor
sacó una armónica como esta
la desarmó para que viéramos cómo
funcionaba las armónicas por dentro
tienen una serie de lengüetas de metal
que vibran con el aire que ponemos en
ella y eso produce el sonido algo así
[Música]
esto
hace justamente una vibración en el aire
y produce el sonido y si es mi segundo
objeto esa misma tarde fui a la ciudad a
hacer mi kinesioterapia con la terapeuta
y me mostró un nuevo dispositivo para
trabajar se llamaba capella por
curiosidad le pregunté cómo funcionaba
también quizás para divertirme porque
básicamente era un tubo más en el que
había que soplar
y cuando lo abrió adentro había una
lengüeta que vibraba con el aire me
explico como por una resonancia mecánica
esa vibración pasa a los pulmones y
sacas el moco como la armónica le grite
es muy posible que esa kinesióloga haya
pensado que estaba un poco loca tampoco
podemos culpar la después de esa
reacción
fue el año siguiente cuando salió la
posibilidad de realizar un proyecto de
ciencias en la escuela y ahí dije por
qué no compré un par de armónicas le
pedí a un par de amigos fibroquísticos
que fueran conejillos de indias y nos
largamos a probar
la idea era ver si la armónica
funcionaba mejor que la capella y nos
permitía reemplazar la kinesioterapia
por tocar la armónica y bueno no voy a
mentirles tampoco quería estar en clase
a nivel resultados no nos fue como
esperábamos salvo por lo menos estar en
clases que ahí siempre me he
caracterizado solo por excelencia
la armónica funcionaba similar a la
capella no mejor
y la gran variedad de técnicas de la
kinesio no permitía que un solo
instrumento la reemplazar en su
totalidad sin embargo era un excelente
complemento y además apareció algo que
no se me había ocurrido empezaron a
decir los fibroquísticos que habían
probado che qué buena está la armónica
divertido otro día me junté a tocar con
un amigo que toca la guitarra para que
así cualquier hacer tratamiento
que claro no no se me había cruzado por
la cabeza por lo puse en los formularios
que es más divertido más llenador más
motivador
hacer música que tocar un instrumento
que hacer tratamiento pasó un poco en mi
cerebro
y es el archivo
a raíz también de esto
me di cuenta que los fibroquísticos
pasamos mucho tiempo solos no importa
que tan de fierros sean tus amigos tu
familia y créanme que los fibroquísticos
tenemos amigos y familias muy de fierro
pero tienen una vida es imposible estar
con alguien dos horas de la mañana
torras a la noche durante todos los días
del año
aquí es donde les voy a presentar al
tercer objeto esta compañera
con una mía decidimos no solo estudiar
los efectos de los instrumentos
musicales en el tratamiento de la
fibrosis quística sino los deportes
elegimos al vóley porque era el deporte
que jugamos y llamamos al proyecto
movimiento en clave de sol
los beneficios del deporte los conocemos
todos y son también para todos regula la
presión arterial mejora el sistema
locomotor optimiza nuestro sistema
cardiovascular para los fibroquísticos
el deporte aumenta nuestra capacidad
respiratoria que se traduce en más años
de vida
mejora la fuerza de nuestra caja
torácica que nos permite resistir las
infecciones y hace que compartamos
nuestro tratamiento con otras personas
personalmente el voley ha sido el ámbito
donde he buscado el secuaz para la idea
loca de turno
este proyecto fue con una compañera de
voley soy bea' de ingenieras mi tesis la
hice con otra compañera de voley dejaba
el compañero
vivo con una compañera de voley pero que
claro cuando compartís con un grupo de
personas tres o cuatro días a la semana
es imposible que se formen lazos es
imposible que ese compartir no te lleve
a hacer amigos
el deporte te pone límites tanto
emocionales como físicos
finalmente
cuando la pelota está en el aire
todos somos iguales importa si tenés una
enfermedad o que carga tenéis en la
espalda
simplemente no dejes que ella toque el
pis
simplemente no dejen que se caiga
les pregunté si se acordaban la primera
vez que habían inflado un blog yo la
tengo muy presente no fui capaz de
inflar un globo hasta los 21 años a esa
edad estuve más de un mes internada y
pasé por tres operaciones de pulmón
cuando salí
luego miré al médico y le pregunté
cuándo puedo volver a jugar pero bueno
quieres volver a jugar primero inflar un
globo
cuando fue la primera vez que en flash t
un globo la mía fue febrero del 2017
qué significa la música y el deporte
para vos
para mí significa la oportunidad de
realizar todos los días el tratamiento
de una forma que me llene
en las enfermedades crónicas todos los
días salimos a jugar nuestro partido y
días que ganamos hay días que perdemos
pero como dice mi entrenador
para ganar lo primero que hay que hacer
es no abandonar
y es por eso
que los invito a cada uno te invito a
vos a voz a voz a ser inquietos a ser
curiosos a usar tu creatividad y
animarte a darle una vuelta a este
problema que puedes estar teniendo hoy
nadie está exento de tener una
discapacidad en algún momento de su vida
y saben que a pesar de esto no se trata
de cómo es tu vida
se trata de como elegís vivirla y a
veces no nos queda otra que honrarlas
por los que no están teniendo esa opción
están acá con nosotros
los invito
a esto y tal vez así en algún momento
algún día se encuentra en un lugar y
hagan algo que durante muchos años
creyeron imposibles me van a acompañar
ah
y bueno
[Aplausos]